Stephen Breyer I'm a justice of the
united states supreme court sometimes
when I have a difficult decision and and
it's very a very close question rather
basic question what is really leading me
in this direction rather than that
direction what what is it that's making
me see where i might go here I think
it's San Francisco Lowell High School
1955 1953 it's a it was a very open city
was a wonderful place we lived in the
city my father was a lawyer for the San
Francisco school board I still have his
watch it's his watch it says Irving
brighter you San Francisco Unified
School District 1933 to 1973 he was born
in San Francisco his father moved there
and I guess before the turn of the 20th
century my mother was from st. Paul
she'd moved out I had one brother was
younger and San Francisco is a as I say
a wonderful place because it was you
could very easily get to the mountains
or you go I was in the Boy Scouts I love
the boy scouts we go on hiking trips I
we could you could go across the bay the
weather was good I spent lots of
different communities I spent the
summers one summer working at the PG&E
one summer they had a camp camp mather
which was a city camp and they had lots
of people their lawyers they're
policemen firemen not very many black
people very interested and the but it
was in in many many respects it there
there were there were not great
divisions in the community and I don't
think we realized how lucky we were it
didn't take a lot of money really didn't
and today I guess you'd have to have a
lot of money to live the way we lived in
without very much at all the the times
were good but made it I mean I the Boy
Scouts grant school
Lowell High School they're part of my
life my mother said that I seemed as as
happy in the my senior year in high
school which has its ups and downs as I
might ever be the the we didn't know too
much about the real problems in the
country i would say that i mean their
problems of race that we hardly knew
existed in San Francisco but they were
right in front of us and gradually got
to see what they were I can remember my
mother telling me one day she had a
friend who was black and they wanted to
go to a restaurant for lunch and they
were going to go to the st. Francis
hotel and they were discussing whether
they could and that was San Francisco
that wasn't the south we can go is
brought in justice i would say in
tremendous influence on me from that
time looking back was the fact that my
father worked for the city government
and my mother was interested in city
life so it was natural for me to think
that it's important to be part of a city
of a group of a community and an
important part of your life is involved
in work that will keep you in touch with
other people in the community that's
certainly what their live show and it
also showed me there are a million ways
that you could possibly have that
connection with the community but i can
remember thinking when i was a teenager
and we had some friends who lived you
started out saying it was a suburb it
wasn't a suburb and i wondered how could
people live in a suburb because if they
lived in a suburb they wouldn't really
be in touch with what's going on in the
city and i understood after a while but
but that that part civic life community
life whether it was temple emanuel or
whether it was a city school board or
that was the school department or
whether it was the United Nations
Association my more she worked in
political campaigns sometimes my mother
so that that I think had a tremendous
influence in in my life
always there a teacher in everybody's
life you had a teacher there was
mischief Chester in the in the seventh
grade there was mr. Englander in high
school who said that I didn't really
know nearly as much as I thought I did
that was a good lesson I haven't really
developed a theory of the law didn't try
to develop a theory until I thought it
was necessary and it isn't really a
theory to explain to people how our
court works and how I and others try to
think about the application of a
constitution to problems that come up in
front of the court I mean that led me to
write about it and that's what you're
thinking about and and of course I
suppose but at the heart of the
Constitution but it isn't only me it's
sandro Connor who had a very different
backgrounds you have done a ranch
interestingly enough we've talked about
this Tony Kennedy to Tony Kennedy's
really from San Francisco Sacramento
Northern California but I think in my
own case it puts I see the Constitution
as having the democratic process at the
heart of it of having it the the the
central element of the Constitution is
creating institutions so people can
decide things for themselves and often I
like to refer back and say well that's
probably what the founders had in mind
or the framers had in mind when they
thought of the Greek city-states or were
they were writing the Constitution but
perhaps since you raised the point it's
also what i saw in San position
Oh